hi reject nation of Greg Alba and I'm
John Humphrey we are going to talk about
the movie that is doing okay at the box
office right now called first men
directed by Damon chiselled it's not
about music given there's some good
music in here it's about thing you know
some stuff that happened in real life
there's a good intro solid right now and
I used to have in my hair being down
anymore person who are you stiff right
now before we hop into this video I want
to say thank you to everyone who's been
following us over at the Stardust app
over there we do 30-second reactions
from any film TV show or trailer it's a
free app to use it's free to download we
post regularly honor there's other
youtubers as well is not a sponsored
video but we post so much that we wanted
you guys to follow us in fact here's our
reaction the first man first man in a
few minutes
well it's loaded with breathtaking
visuals it's most realistic space we've
ever seen game she's out she's nursing
her from the perspective Neil Armstrong
often times better watch the crazy shot
them outside of Baker forever but
raining off you're just the terrifying
to some of them I feel like we have to
not music fantastic sent on three times
not great
[ __ ] parks is all about right do feel
rather detached from the characters
which prevent through community a 5 out
of 5 let's go worth the price when we
miss out on that
anyway let's talk about first man the
title has the word spoilers in it kind
of weird to say that cuz 99% of this
movie you probably heard about it right
of the book you read the book or you've
seen some documentaries or whatever you
know like student of history at any time
though this is already talked about in
real life I'm putting the word spoiler
in the title because I really want to
touch on the moon landing specifically
because that's where some controversial
stuff has been brought up there's
something that happens in there that
people are questioning how made-up that
is or if that really happened and in
order to do that it's a spoiler so
that's that's really the only thing that
it was probably only present in this
movie that you have might not find
anywhere else I really enjoyed this
movie we saw it at Universal IMAX which
is a real IMAX drink I want to point
something out really quick
the marketing on this movie at the
Universal Theatre is kind of misleading
the only sequence in IMAX cameras is the
moon landing sequence everything on the
actual surface of the Moon is full-frame
IMAX but once you're in back in a ship
or back on earth or anything like that
your back is yeah regular 35-millimeter
aspect ratio it's just the marketing of
it if you saw the trailer kind of has
you thinking oh a lot of this wrong it's
cool when it happens it's a great
transition into what it goes on but but
it does lead you to thinking part way
through the movie like what regardless
though this movie spans eight years it's
all up to the Apollo 11 mission of the
first time man reached the moon and this
is really like a Neil Armstrong and in a
way a biopic of his life and yeah he is
the central figure that guides us
through yes part of the space race and
there's a lot of uniqueness to this
because usually for a film like this
you're probably going in thinking you're
gonna watch some really inspirational
tale that's primarily the mission of
going because it's a ten days for them
to get to the moon you probably think
you're gonna spend most of your time
with with this mission yeah it's like
right stuff yeah like the first half is
leading up and then the last half is all
that but really majority of this almost
two hour and 20 minute film majority of
it is the problems the trial and errors
of leading up to this mission it took
like eight years for them to finally be
able to get to go so you're spanning a
lot of time in a little over two hours
yeah I know and you're not really
separating it up into acts so much as
chapters because each the movie kind of
flows in this way of each chapter is a
different test or a different mission
and also a different moment in Neil's
life leading with some positives here
this is an amazing technical achievement
like an astounding technical it's
arguably the most realistic space movie
I've ever seen
there were times where I had to question
just how much did Universal throw at
this movie how much money I'm like did
they launch like a bunch of real rockets
in his face
what is CGI in this movie yeah yeah one
apparently at least from some of the
interviews I've heard they did their
best to get as much of it all in camera
as
yeah a lot of miniature work there's a
lot of stuff they did with screens
outside of ya nose and adding real
elements you know on top of it to make
it feels realistic as possible and it
really does translate because I spent
half this movie going how did you do
this you're also in such a tight view of
everything like everything is really
locked into a human point of view
primarily the perspective of Neil
Armstrong who whose view you're locked
into during this film in a literal and a
contextual standpoint it primarily hops
back and forth between Neil Armstrong's
point-of-view like most of this is
through his perspective when you're in
the you know like there's any tests or
spaceships or whatever a lot of it is
this like crazy shaky shot of just
putting it into the shoes of what it
must be like for an astronaut to
experiences so most films would probably
do outside shots or have really smooth
steady shot so you could really capture
the beauty of this this really captures
like the grimy ugliness it looks
unappealing to deal with it he doesn't
look Pleasant there's so much of the
mental and physical taxation is there
on-screen because you got to think like
these dudes are hopping into these test
simulators that are like gyroscopes that
are throwing you all around and push you
in g-force and guys are passing yeah
throwing up you gotta go and do this
again and get used to it and you know
when they're in the Rockets like they're
all these incessant noises and blinking
lights and you're people dying and you
have like the actual human risks of
everything and you start to think like
the psychological state of somebody
willing to do this must be extreme and
the movie does a good job at setting
that up or Neil is about to you know get
interviewed to be part of this NASA
program they do a knowledge that this is
primarily gonna be a psychological test
everything they're gonna be doing that's
the most important factor and then you
see why because there's always a sense
of danger that someone's gonna die it
just it just in the testing if there's
one thing this movie really did for me
as a huge takeaway was it made me
appreciate just how much effort how much
sacrifice not just time and energy and
commitment but lives that were
sacrificed in order to complete this
mission and now we have so much
developed from NASA since 1969 I didn't
realize it took this long I wasn't fully
aware of how this was an eight-year
period and how the world was reacting to
the programs that
going on before they successfully made
it to the moon there was so much that I
had never factored in to history yeah
like I'd known about the Space wars I
know that it was a competition with
Russia they like pretty much get to the
moon first and the movie does a pretty
good job at touching on that element of
you know what's the real purpose of
going here even asking at one point
why why do we need to go two spaces yeah
and why do you think it's valuable to go
to space admittedly in the end I was
still there going why one of the things
that I did appreciate them for doing is
like we've seen movies about this and
we've seen the space race element of us
versus the Russians patriotic but I do
appreciate it totally so that's what
that movie what I appreciated they
brought in like the public's point of
view just in the background a few times
it seemed like yeah a lot of like just
the people of America we're not entirely
on board as much attention as everybody
paid there are a lot of people really
against this both on the scale of like
you're gonna lose a lot of people in the
pursuit of this because no matter how
much control you think you have this is
all about trial and error to go yeah and
you also have the the opposite
standpoint of just class and culture of
you know they play Whitey's on the moon
because it's also about how much
problems that are down here that aren't
being addressed because we're dumping
money into going to space it touches
slightly on the political stuff like
it's definitely an important factor in
the movie but it's not really about that
where I feel like most movies especially
in the way they would approach them like
this you would probably have a lot more
of the fun training sequences you
probably have a much bigger sense of
wonder there's only like a couple of
moments that I can really recall work oh
there's the moment of wonder of SpaceX
parade like there's a couple of times
they see like the atmosphere and the
horizon line or when they first see the
moon when they're approaching it and
that's about it yeah this movie is like
a [ __ ] struggle it is a Spielberg
Wonder it's like a breathtaking sort of
oh my god a little bit of horrifying
element oh it's really that's that's one
flavor this movie has very thoroughly
throughout is its kind of horrifying
like it's very absolute literal and
upsetting in a way like it's very
claustrophobic and shrill so going back
a little
but now and because that's where this
movie completely excels and to me that's
where it seems like that's where Damien
Chazelle main heart was at was exploring
the history behind this helping educate
especially people like myself who
weren't around for this time or never
bother to look it up really pay
attention to the history to go look how
much work and effort and sacrifice was
put into this and how dangerous all this
is just how it sanely scary this is and
with that element being played in this
is a neil armstrong biopic a part of
this movie though the real theme that
resonates throughout especially within
the arc and this is why i feel like we
have to touch on the ending is grief the
beginning of this movie starts off with
neil armstrong i mean it's not the very
very it's like tim isn't right it's one
of the first major plot points which
drives the whole character of neil
armstrong like i I don't know how
accurate all that is it was specifically
in terms of real life but in terms of
storytelling and a movie this is the
main drive is he loses his daughter
Gosling is excels at like the quiet
performances the thousand mile stairs
arrive is my favorite performance of him
he's good at that and it works well for
this character because the way they
portray Neil Armstrong here is a stoic
guy very emotionally distant guy because
when he loses his daughter there's this
very specific moment that stood out to
me that I think kind of touches on
themes of what it must have been like to
be a man and that time period is like
nowadays is so much easier for men to
not easy but easy you're more acceptable
for men to express their emotions cry
whatever but even at his funeral for his
daughter there's a moment where he goes
to a room he's holding his daughter's
bracelet he starts like bawling in that
room by himself but he he doesn't allow
people to come into his heart and
there's never really exposition about it
just kind of watch that happen and
that's part of the flavor of this film
is this really gritty handheld work it
with such subtle acting throughout that
you're sort of peering into their lives
throughout it and especially with Neil
Armstrong because the more death he
encounters you know like on this space
program constantly getting closer with
other astronauts other engineers and
then people keep freaking dying yeah
just in the pursuit of this [ __ ]
it seemed like it was always progress
death progress death you know so what
you watch happen with Neil in this film
it's he becomes more and more distant
angsty closed-off yeah I mean it seems
like he's about aggressive yeah there's
this whole controversy that came out
with Ryan Gosling saying that he thinks
Neil Armstrong didn't view himself as an
American hero which of course gets
flipped what's this about he's not an
American Hero yes the moon sucks and
then when you watch this movie you
totally get what he meant by that
because when I'm watching the film I
never viewed him as this American Hero
and NORs the character himself of Neil
Armstrong in the film ever treats
himself that way we got to do this for
America and I've heard of a few people
touch on this and I had the same thing
going in is like I feel like a lot of us
growing up you just learn in school
about how we got to space you hear about
Neil Armstrong a little bit and you
think oh yeah this guy must be kind of
like a Captain America yeah you know but
he at least as by this film's portrayal
and from everything I can gather from
the you know the research they
apparently did it seems like he might
not have been the type to view himself
as somebody doing something triumphant
for the country so much as just pursuing
the only thing that seems to give his
life any perfect yeah it seems like how
I interpreted this whole space mission
he went on like wanting to do all this
in a lot of ways a coping mechanism but
also an escape to deal with truly
grieving over the loss of his daughter
and the more they failed the more people
died the more aggressive he got about
succeeding in the mission the more
people were saying we should slow down
we shouldn't do this the more distant he
got from his family and the more
aggressive he became about getting to
the freaking moon you know like
completing that for some reason like I
said what Damien Chazelle really seem to
care about was all those elements I feel
like the heart it was really on display
with the history the exploring NASA
going on going on this mission but then
it's the characters themselves everyone
does a great job in terms of acting
Claire Foy is amazing in this film in
some ways her performance kind of stands
out to me more than Ryan Gosling's in
this movie maybe because she gets to get
to see
that you're like oscar-winning speech
right there and I think that she gets
those kind of scenes yeah and while
Brian goslings performance is certainly
appropriate for this it is something
that I've seen him do before so some of
the other performance were just a bit
more surprising I was telling John
before we filmed Claire Foy I think is
amazing Ryan Gosling does a great job
too but there's something about when
they're together were I never quite felt
in terms of character all right I'm not
talking about history and context of
other apps like am I just in the
characters moon laid a bubble of this
movie yeah I was like wait dad these two
exactly end up together you know I mean
she says a line about she wanted a
normal life but I don't really see the
dynamics maybe that's because the movie
starts off with their daughters dying
and then she dies and so there's this
distance it's something created they
allude to their times in college
together but you never get to see that
stuff you know all the family scenes I
could there's something about this when
I was watching it where I could imagine
Damien Chazelle like interviews I
haven't seen a single one but I can
imagine the interviews of him being
along the lines of yeah I wanted to tell
this story about you know Apollo 11
going to the moon well you had to ground
it in something that's real personal so
you know working off the death of his
daughter and his family like I
appreciated all the intent with having
family moments cause a lot of it was
like space time space stuff space stuff
and then some family stuff family stuff
and there is something about those
family moments that never quite hit me
in the way that I think the film wanted
to and I think there's an argument to be
made there there was something that was
just kind of missing for me in terms of
a real character emotional investment
and that's the only thing that keeps me
from loving this movie was that their
acting is great they do service for the
characters it's not like they're lazy or
don't give a [ __ ] about it but there was
something there that felt left me kind
of a little bit empty on on the side of
truly being invested in truly being
interested in what I was watching with
the character and being moved
yes-no side of the movie yeah the
personal side of the movie because there
is so much that is shot like you're a
fly on the wall like it's a documentary
like you're a person in the room just
watching these little moments play out
when I first came out of the theater I
wasn't sure exactly how that clicked on
me and I do feel like this movie
probably moved me a little bit more than
it moved you I have no idea why like
that was kind of the gist of our
preliminary discussion was sort of like
what
that element that might be missing and I
think for me I think just the movie
draws the situation from every angle so
well that I think it bridged the gap of
all the emotional stuff where I was like
just for any human involved in this
situation it's got to be a tough life
you know it's got to be a taxing strange
life because you're dealing with so many
things that none of us will ever have to
juggle I think that kind of bridged the
emotional gap for me but I do kind of
see that it is a very distant movie your
Center your emotional center is cold you
know some people might justify that with
saying well you know Neil Armstrong was
a distant guy he's a cold guy so how can
you really love it and it's not that I
even have to love these people you can
still be invested in find people very
fascinating and interesting without
loving them well the age-old debate
about about movies is like you know just
because that's how it really is doesn't
necessarily mean it will be narrative ly
satisfying yeah see that's that's why
people change things like it seemed like
the most authentic heartfelt investment
came from all this stuff outside of that
and then Damien Chazelle really wanted
to intertwine a lot of this family stuff
as the thing that is the main emotional
core of this journey is the family stuff
his grieving tale but that felt so
secondary for me I get it
I feel why all these things are kind of
drawbacks to just the impact the movie
leaves but on a logical standpoint I get
why they unfolded that way just given
who your central figure is I feel like
most of the emotion comes from everybody
else around Neil Armstrong we just don't
get to spend that much time with anybody
else because he's not really that
invested in spending time with you have
any other people so the brief moments of
levity or or you know humor smiles any
of that are always fleeting yeah you
know yeah it's I I can't quite pinpoint
it because there's this really big scene
in the movie that I think a lot of
people are probably touching on when
Neil has to tell his kids that he might
not be coming home it was a great scene
leading up to that that's also a really
good moment but even in that scene like
there's something about this is not
quite impacting me the way I feel like I
should be other than that that's the
only thing that keeps me from giving
this like a 5 out of 5 I get the
characters attached but I kind of feel
detached
from the characters experiences and
stuff that that's and it's like because
I feel like if I had that extra of nudge
every part of this would have felt that
much more elevated basically but then
going to the ending of this film you get
to the moon and there's just crazy
transitional shot words like they opened
the hatchet it was an IMAX format and
all the sound goes away space makes
sense what's cool about that is even
though the marketing of that kind of
upset me it's used in a character way
which I appreciate it because it was
more than just some cool gimmick to try
to get some seats it's used in a way of
oh wow now you this whole movies about
putting you in their freakin shoes it's
just with respect to the approach like
that is a beautiful transition into the
IMAX like take all that other stuff
aside you can tell like yeah that was a
choice and it was a good choice yeah
yeah they don't show them planning the
fleecy the freaking flak you see them do
it to see them pounding the thing into
the ground and it's in the background
they just don't have like an up angle
shot of like you know triumphant trumpet
sound as they play in it and then like a
solar flare from behind as if whatever
atmosphere the movements might have you
know the same time I'm like III don't
think that did tracks anything did they
make it likes everyone
they made it well they made them the
movie makes it pretty clear that this is
a mission for America and it has also
that the effect that it has on the world
in this that this is America's
accomplishment sorry you guys think it
your [ __ ] Flags evil but guys it's it
doesn't take away any of the points that
you are think are missing because of
this one moment honestly it doesn't this
is about showing you from Neil
Armstrong's perspective they have this
moment that I found honey I don't know
how any lost response with I found a guy
here buzz and Neil are watching JFK give
one of the most historical speeches and
talking about why we went to the moon
and all the creational yeah and they're
kind of just like they don't understand
how hard this was the way they're
watching is like we on of us do we don't
were they we're lead are not feeling the
way how the rest of the world is feeling
about it you know I think the
controversial part to that's been
brought up is
weirdly the moment that's been debated
of whether or not it's true is the
moment that arguably affected me the
most in this whole film because it
completes Neil's art is when he has his
daughter's bracelet which I like kind of
the semi foreshadowing of it of what
buzz is like yeah I'm gonna bring my
wife's jewelry and he's like what would
you bring he's not telling the crowd my
way Buzz Aldrin portrays like a total
dick because I have the kind of the same
view of all the astronauts from when we
learned about him as kids so I'm like is
that true is he kind of an uncouth dude
was he he's a that guy yeah movie every
time he opens his mouth he's like you're
that guy here we got Corey Stoll who
plays good and he doesn't but he's
holding his daughter's bracelet and you
could see he's gonna throw it in the
moon that moment got me a little
misty-eyed
honestly because that's the point of
this film he's grieving like in terms of
the character study of Neil Armstrong
he's grieving he sets out on this
mission because it's an escape and a
distraction from his daughter and in the
moment of him completing this mission he
doesn't look like a happy camper the
other two astronauts do their jumping
around and he's just doing his Ryan
Gosling staring and like yep finally
here it still feels like this lack of
fulfillment because at the end of the
day what he really wanted his daughter
back so by him completing this mission
in that moment he's like finally letting
her go throwing the thing he held onto
with her was that bracelet and he's
throwing it into the moon completing the
mission is simultaneously him letting go
of this grief that he's held onto for
nearly a decade at this point of that
ending because I didn't know him and
Janet got divorced to lie for the movie
watch who's killed walk in there she was
going and go I wanted you just got back
from the moon yeah well I mean I learned
a bit there's one detail toward the end
of this movie that did confuse me that
would make that response even more like
there's a point where they basically
type up these letters that as I took it
are basically saying your husband's are
not coming back from this mission
ostensibly they send them out oh yeah I
was like yeah you must your mind must be
[ __ ] up coming back and being like oh
you're here interest yeah yeah and I
could definitely see why they would have
gotten a divorce I think this movie does
a great job that edge
I mean even though the end credits will
say like they tweak stuff and they
change stuff as I'm glad I acknowledge
that yeah I think it does a good job at
giving you an understanding really
setting up what it must have really been
like for these astronauts to go on these
missions the lives of sacrifices that
were made it's not doesn't feel like an
inspirational tale yet there's there's
inspirations you could take from it in
terms of learning to fail learning to be
okay with failing and keep on going no
matter what it's inspiring for
perseverance alone you know this is the
biggest film sure Zell it's done but it
still has similar themes I think giving
a whiplash in la-la-land Neil Armstrong
in this movie they're all stories of
people ambitions and then sacrifices for
their own self humanity and and and the
people they love everything that's gonna
get lost the cost that comes with
succeeding at what you're aiming for
yeah especially when what you're aiming
for is like literally out of that world
and has never been done before and
you're just trial and error in your way
up to the time and you make it and it's
not as rewarding as you thought it would
be yeah all that you've lost along the
way
yeah if Edgar Wright has a Cornetto
trilogy this should be his like
ambitious sacrifice trilogy yeah like I
got some vibes especially from the more
human size of the story like I got some
like Aronofsky or PT Anderson this felt
like a teriyaki film yeah especially in
the way it's like you know a person kind
of obsessed with this one objective and
yeah I'm letting it consume and twist up
their life mean yeah for me ever give
like a solid four out of five for sure
like that would be my solid rating see
I'm having trouble figuring out what the
element is that kind of endears me a bit
more so I probably go with like a four
and a half okay you know there I feel
like the emotional side maybe didn't a
hundred percent but I did get a lot more
of it than that I think maybe it hit you
so yeah alright guys well what did you
think of first man did you love it does
it live up to the hype are you a history
buff and that's why you love it
automatically I don't know just cleave
your comments below you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification download the starter
step and follow us right away it's free
[Applause]